[Musique]
bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
politique à table sur LCP et cette
semaine nous recevons
Erwan Balan avec lui on va parler
cuisine alimentation agriculture
écologie et aussi politique et avec moi
pour présenter cette émission
Jean-Pierre Montanet bonjour Jean-Pierre
bonjour Brigitte et bonjour
Erwan bonjour
Erwan Balanant vous êtes député MoDem du
Finistère membre du parti centriste
depuis sa création en 2007 vous le
quittez en 2015 après avoir participé en
2012 à la campagne de François Bayrou en
2017 vous êtes investi par la République
en marche et vous intégrez finalement le
groupe modem on n'échappe pas son destin
mais à quel destin étiez-vous destiné
vous
Erwan Balanant titulaire d'une maîtrise
d'histoire contemporaine vous intégrez
l’ennecy et l'École du Louvre vous avez
été athlète de haut niveau membre de
l'équipe de France espoir de saut en
hauteur puis photographe réalisateur
vous allez travailler avec Florent Pagny
ou Marc Lavoine avant de vous tourner
vers la politique alors plusieurs
trajectoires plusieurs vies
un cap la Bretagne et ses embruns qui en
disent long sur le menu du jour
Jean-Pierre 100% breton des coquilles
Saint-Jacques avec une touche d'exotisme
et une sauce aux fruits de la passion
une mousseline de céleri et en dessert
un gâteau
breton dans le dessous des plats le
beurre ne compte pas pour du beurre
adulte comme enfant après le faire
eux-mêmes reportage à la ferme de Gally
dans les pieds dans le plat l'artichaut
breton se fait rare sur les étals il
crève de soif en raison d'une sécheresse
historique allez on passe à table tout
de suite cuisine et confidence
[Musique]
Erwan balano à mes yeux ce menu traduit
chez vous une grande lassitude sans
doute que cette ambiance de chaudron à
l'Assemblée sans jeu de mots culinaire
vous pèse et donc rien de tel qu'un bon
gueuleton pour passer à autre chose mais
c'est là que les choses se compliquent
Brigitte que peut-on décemment déguster
aujourd'hui sans se faire démolir avec
votre étiquette de centriste vous êtes
bien trop raisonnable pour exiger du
foie gras pas envie d'être condamné pour
complicité de maltraitance sur des
canards en plus rescapés d'un carnage la
grippe aviaire alors la bonne viande
rouge pourquoi pas non impossible
aujourd'hui incarnation du virilisme et
de l'élevage intensif pour certains du
caviar encore pire n'en parlons pas pas
du tout d'actualité au moment où les
régimes des barbus iraniens vastille
sous la colère des femmes antivoi bref
pour faire gastro sans vous faire
dézinguer il ne restait donc plus que
ces bonnes vieilles coquilles
Saint-Jacques symbole d'abord de votre
terroir marin et Breton et surtout en
cet automne de pêche miraculeuse jamais
l'espèce ne s'est aussi bien portée
notamment sur les côtes normandes grâce
à la réglementation très stricte
française donc vous pourrez vous régaler
sans mauvaise conscience est-ce que je
me trompe Erwan Balanant j'ai rarement
mauvaise conscience quand je
quand je déjeune ou quand je dis j'adore
j'adore la cuisine j'adore manger
j'adore essayer aussi de de faire des
plats c'est préparer des plats et on a
une richesse en Bretagne effectivement
culinaire très forte avec une variété
des produits des produits de la mer et
des produits de la terre et ça permet
une créativité énorme on peut manger en
Bretagne juste un plateau de fruits de
mer juste avec une très bonne mayonnaise
du pain et du beurre mais aussi on peut
manger des plats plus sophistiqués qui
mélangent nos traditions qui peuvent
mélanger les produits terriens et les
produits de la mer et on a cette
vraiment cette variété de poisson de
type de coquille de coquilles
Saint-Jacques de on a maintenant même
des nouveautés le poulpe alors ça pose
quelques sujets sur mon territoire parce
que les poules ont un petit peu dégommer
la bête
Saint-Jacques vous avez remarqué chez
vous par exemple il y a moins ou pas
chez moi à Concarneau c'est dramatique
pour les coquilles Saint-Jacques mais
homard aussi
la filière c'est très bien réorganisé
pour pêcher les poules et les revendre
donc voilà pour l'instant les pêcheurs
de les pêcheurs de Concarneau voilà mais
on va avoir une question sur sur la
coquille sur le dans la baie de
Concarneau jusqu'au Glénans on a une
très bonne coquille aussi on parle
souvent de la coquille de Saint-Brieuc
mais chez nous on en a une très bonne
aussi mais là c'est un peu compliqué
pour la coquille voilà et cette coquille
Saint-Jacques on va la déguster ensemble
si vous le voulez bien parce que c'est
difficile de cuire la coquille
Saint-Jacques je pense que la cuisson
est très importante non vous allez
peut-être me garantir il y a plein de
façons je veux en parler d'astuces pour
en parler mais peut-être que vous avez
une façon aussi moi j'ai la coquille
Saint-Jacques je l'aime soit en
carpaccio j'adore ça
voilà et sinon j'aime énormément chez
nous je sais pas si on peut faire de la
publicité mais chez nous on a un
conservateur historique qui fait un
conflit de coquilles Saint-Jacques qui
se mange vous savez qu'on peut reprendre
et remettre dans la dans la dans la
coque c'est délicieux c'est super simple
à faire et c'est extrêmement bon c'est
une entreprise qui fait ça en Bretagne
depuis c'est une recette historique
alors il y a beaucoup de beurre dedans
et c'est on va en parler du beurre parce
que je j'espère bien qu'on va parler du
beurre
trois choses à savoir pour sublimer la
coquille Saint-Jacques
d'abord quadriller délicatement soit
avec un couteau avec une fine lame soit
avec un coupof pour un quadrillage le 2
Pro comme au resto et à la cuisson
mettez bien la face quadrillée
directement en contact avec la poêle et
faites les revenir dans du beurre
j'allais dire un beurre bien chaud deux
minutes de chaque côté pour qu'elle soit
juste snackée si vous les adorez comme
c'est le cas des rois de balano en
carpaccio pour ne pas obtenir parce que
c'est ça le danger de la charpie de
Saint-Jacques en taillant les noix
placez d'abord 30 minutes au congélateur
pas trop dur non plus parce que ça va
être des cailloux 30 minutes ça suffit
et ensuite elles seront légèrement durci
et elles vont se laisser escaloper c'est
le terme technique plus facilement et
surtout plus finement pour la finition
j'allais dire déposer quelques gouttes
d'huile de vanille c'est assez raffiné
enfin si vous tentiez le crumble de
Saint-Jacques et bien laissez la
Saint-Jacques dans le fond du ramequin
avec une fondue de poireau par exemple
une sauce un peu crémée surmontée de
cette couche de pâte sablée qui
ressemble à du sable vous mettez un peu
de parmesan quelques minutes au four et
le tour est joué et c'est pas mauvais
c'est original ouais ouais ça me plaît
il y a c'est sucré salé sucré salé et
puis c'est ça l'avantage de la coquille
Saint-Jacques c'est c'est ça permet ça
permet vraiment de la créativité souvent
par exemple avec des poireaux c'est très
bon mais là c'est du céleri une petite
fondue de poireaux avec un peu de crème
fraîche un peu de beurre votre collègue
Gosselin il était venu aussi de Normand
et il avait pris avec du lard ah oui
bien aussi le mélange terre vous aimez
ça j'adore ça j'adore ça Terre Mère et
puis surtout légumes poissons j'aime
bien ce qu'on peut ce qu'on peut
chercher à faire et vous avez parlé des
carpaccio de Saint-Jacques moi j'adore
une recette toute simple c'est vous
faites des lamelles comme vous l'avez
dit effectivement un peu de congélateur
avant ça permet bien les couper avec des
alternes tranches de Saint-Jacques et
des fines tranches de gingembre juste
citron ah oui c'est pas vous laisser
mariner un peu d'huile d'olive vous
voyez je suis pas non plus un ayatollah
du beurre je suis capable de mettre de
l'huile d'olive vous laissez mariner un
petit peu et c'est délicieux mais on
sent le cuistot on sent que vous aimez
ça parce qu'il y en a pas beaucoup qui
nous disent qu'il coupe des des j'aime
bien j'aime bien cuisiner j'aime bien
cuisiner
on a souvent peu de temps pour cuisiner
dans la semaine et j'aime bien le
dimanche essayer de cuisiner et c'est
pour ça et donc cuisiner qu'en cuisine
c'est bien d'avoir des amis et donc
j'aime bien avoir du monde à la partage
alors c'est toujours des produits du
terroir vous ce que vous avez moi je ne
sais pas du jour je fais mes courses que
plein de choses et c'est des valeurs
importantes qu'il y a autour de la
cuisine alors Jean-Pierre Raymond vient
dîner chez vous ce week-end qu'est-ce
que vous nous préparez alors ce week-end
je sais pas je ferai simple vraiment si
mais ça sera bon ça sera très bon alors
deux solutions soit
très bon soit je vous fais des si vous
êtes plutôt poissons je vous ferai des
sols meunières traditionnelles avec des
frites des très bonnes frites
frites maison donc ça fait une sorte de
fish and chips ou alors je vous ou alors
si vous êtes plutôt viande je vous fais
une volaille et je vous fais un poulet
en cuisson lente
farcis
un peu moins de 60 un peu moins de 100
combien de temps moi je je me lève le
matin je le mets si on veut déjeuner à
13h 14h il faut au moins le mettre à 9h
quoi il faut se lever
voilà poulet de 6 heures et ça c'est
délicieux parce que il est fondant et
puis le jus le jus descend tout
doucement il brûle pas donc vous pouvez
vous pouvez le remouiller etc c'est très
bon vous le savez avec quoi alors ça ça
peut être parfois des frites parce que
j'aime poulet frites c'est traditionnel
mais sinon sinon je fais des légumes de
chez moi enfin voilà la pomme de terre
c'est aussi pomme de terre la pomme de
terre alors pomme de terre très simple
les pommes de terre c'est bon les pommes
de terre vous faites des petites pommes
de terre quand c'est les pommes de terre
nouvelles de l'ail un peu de beurre un
peu d'herbe de votre jardin alors moi
j'ai un j'ai un potager chez moi
pardon
j'ai un potager surtout pour les herbes
parce que ça c'est simple ça pousse vous
les mettez en vous débutez alors oui
mais j'aime plutôt le temps et
l'estragon aussi oui l'estragon c'est la
sauge la verveine aussi la verveine
qu'on pense mais ça marche aussi très
bien dans les poissons je mélange en
réalité je me fais je prends des herbes
fraîches je les découpe je mélange comme
ça et il y a plein de goûts et quand
manger ça vous fait des petits des
petites surprises tout à l'heure vous
avez dit je n'ai jamais mauvaise
conscience quand je mange mais vous le
Breton vous allez quand même pas chez
votre poissonnière en vous jetant sur un
poisson qui est victime de la surpêche
il s'avère que les poissonniers et la
filière
poissonnerie quand c'est de la pêche
quand vous allez sur dans un magasin et
que c'est pas une grande surface c'est
très rarement de la surpêche parce que
les poissonniers achètent plutôt du
poisson
on voit de il faut pas opposer les deux
la question c'est que on a on a un
potentiel
haliotique marin énorme qui peut nous
produire du poisson il faut juste avoir
des techniques de pêche qui soit qui
préservent la ressource durable et il
faut faire attention il faut faire
confiance à la science et vous savez on
a fait on a réussi des exploits il y
avait des des le thon rouge allait
disparaître aujourd'hui on retrouve du
thon rouge donc il faut avoir une vision
très scientifique
prospective et c'est pour ça qu'on a des
quotas et c'est pour ça qu'il faut les
respecter il y a des espèces qui quand
même qui il faut rester vigilant mais
dont on voit qu'il y a moins de poissons
il faut qu'on soit vigilant il faut
qu'on reste très très vigilant il y a
c'est plus facile pour certaines espèces
pour le ton c'était assez facile parce
qu'on pouvait visualiser les bandes tons
pour nous par exemple vous voyez c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai fait interdire la
pêche électrique ou les Hollandais
voulait nous nous mettre cette pêche qui
a une pêche désastreuse surtout pour les
poissons la sole l'aliment on est tout
ça et maintenant on a un sujet sur sur
ce qu'on appelle la scène danoise où il
va falloir aussi comment dire porter le
combat et c'est des combats qui souvent
se font de manière transpartisane et
c'est ça qui est intéressant mais la
pêche en Bretagne il y a une filière au
turière qui des gros poètes des gros
bateaux qui est un peu en difficulté
aujourd'hui parce que le coût du
carburant fait que ça explose le prix
et il faut qu'on réfléchisse surtout à
les aider pour avoir des bateaux plus
plus économe qui qui fonctionne avec des
grands chalut là n'abîme pas les fonds
marins justement ça dépend comment on
fait effectivement il faut être vigilant
et puis mais je veux parler de ça aussi
on a une pêche côtière en Bretagne qui
elle permet de sortir du poisson
extrêmement varié avec tout type de
poisson et tout type de de
fruits de mer également sauf qu'empêche
côtière on se rend compte que il y a de
moins en moins de macro de
batailles de lieu on
en a d'autres
il y a des cycles donc je suis mauvaise
pécheuse
arrêtez moi si je dis une bêtise mais je
crois que pour les coquilles
Saint-Jacques la réglementation
française est stricte et les outils qui
permettent de ramasser les coquilles
sont plus espacées et laissent donc les
petites copines alors que les Anglais
ramassent même les petites coquilles et
puis surtout les Anglais la filière
coquille Saint-Jacques c'est extrêmement
bien organisé très précise et d'être
très précise des points précis octobre
exactement et quand le tonnage est fait
il y a des fins de saison de pêche voilà
et il faut qu'on fasse la même chose sur
certains
il faut qu'on fasse pédagogie aussi pour
dire il y a certains poissons qu'on ne
mange pas à tel que les poissonniers
c'est important et que le métier de
marayeur et de poissonnier sont des sont
des métiers importants c'est que eux ils
vous disent mais c'est pas le moment de
manger ce poisson puisque c'est des
périodes de frais par exemple par
exemple le bar le bar il y a des moments
faut pas le faut pas manger du bar déjà
il est pas bon c'est pas le moment où il
est le meilleur et c'est le moment où il
se reproduit donc si vous vous achetez
pas le bar à ce moment là il y a pas de
demande et euh oui comme dit Brigitte il
faut le savoir il faut le savoir donc
aller chez votre poissonnier vous m'avez
l'air de bien vous y connaître on va
voir si vous êtes vraiment incollables
c'est le quiz
alors vous l'artiste photographe
réalisateur qui avait travaillé aux
côtés de vimbender pas de canton
Tarantino seriez-vous nous dire dans
quel restaurant parisien a été tourné
cette fameuse réplique de OSS 117 ni
d'espion avec Jean Dujardin comment est
votre blanquette la blanquette est bonne
chez lip la brasserie lip historique à
Paris boulevard Saint-Germain chez
Lapeyrouse autre institution parisienne
à l'auberge Pyrénées Cévennes petit
restaurant du 11e ou au bouillon
Chartier
La Pérouse pire des Cévennes Chartier
j'hésite mais je
j'ai pas de souvenir exact du film à ce
moment là j'hésite entre la Brasserie
Lipp et le bouillon Chartier
Pyrénées
Brigitte on peut réserver oui parce que
non mais pour les fans de cette émission
pour les fans de ce film la table où
était du jardin dans le film et réservé
souvent longtemps à l'avance par les
touristes et effectivement on retrouve
bien si on regarde le film on retrouve
bien en allant dans le restaurant
l'ambiance du film la petite clochette
de la porte quand on ouvre et les
petites toiles au mur voilà pour les
pour les fans de SL vous pouvez vous
rattraper avec un deuxième j'ai vu que
c'était souvent compliqué vos histoires
de quiz likes alors en Bretagne votre
terre il n'y a pas que la Saint-Jacques
qui compte la morue est aussi choyée en
cuisine mais seriez-vous nous dire
quelle recette parmi ces quatre est une
pure invention à morue à la Brestoise B
morue à la quimperoise c'est nombreux à
la Paimpolaise des morues à la
dinardaise
alors je crois qu'il doit y avoir une
façon de faire de la morue dans chaque
ville et chaque port breton donc ça va
être compliqué votre histoire mais j'ai
jamais entendu parler de la morue à la
quimperoise et ben voilà c'est normal
j'avais jamais entendu parler donc
parlez-vous vous dites pas cabillaud non
alors ça dépend en vérité on dit souvent
les gens ils savent pas ce que c'est le
cabillaud le cabillaud c'est la morue
c'est nous on dit souvent on dit le
cabillaud les pêcheurs ils disent le
cabillaud
en fait
une fois qu'elle a été préparée passée
du cabillaud à la préparation à la
salaison
un très bon poisson dans le cabillaud
très très bon alors avec tous ces
poissons et ses fruits de mer on vous a
pris un muscadet ce vin de Loire que
vous affectionnez particulièrement donc
les régions pour pour les vins de Loire
c'est paysanais on joue Touraine et
centre là on est sur le Pays Nantais
Muscadet donc c'est une Appellation
d'Origine Protégée le cépage c'est le
melon de Bourgogne il y a un seul cépage
c'est un cépage unique pour ce Muscadet
qui est donc un vin blanc sec et le
millésime là pour vous c'est un 2020
d'accord alors vous nous dites si j'ai
déjà vous avez vu j'ai déjà
il est très bon et et c'est un vin
breton voilà parce que le Muscadet c'est
le vin historique de la Bretagne c'est
pour ça que que je l'ai choisi et
surtout c'est un pain qui va très bien
avec les fruits de mer et on pourra pas
ne pas parler des huîtres dans cette
émission puisque je suis quand même le
député de la circonscription des huîtres
du Belon qui sont sans doute sans doute
les meilleures huîtres au monde sans
chômage sans chauvinisme aucun non mais
qui sont des huîtres délicieuses et là
c'est pareil l'élevage des huîtres c'est
un savoir-faire extraordinaire qu'il
faut préserver et surtout en gardant
cette dimension
très proche c'est vraiment très proche
de de la mère l'huître c'est-à-dire que
les
ostréiculteurs ont les pieds dans l'eau
si vous passez cette expression et c'est
vraiment un métier voilà dans les parcs
à huîtres et c'est un métier
c'est un métier qui fait vraiment la
transition entre la mer et la terre
parce que si vous voulez avoir des
bonnes huîtres il faut des rillas parce
que chez moi c'est des riads de qualité
et pour avoir des rillettes qualité et
bien il faut être faire attention à la
gestion de l'eau de la ressource et
avoir une agriculture qui soit
respectueuse des eaux et c'est pour ça
que la Bretagne qui parfois a été
critiquée pour son modèle
agroalimentaire en réalité nous avons un
modèle agricole qui est très respectueux
de de la planète et de des écosystèmes
alors oui il y a certains endroits des
grosses porcheries par exemple il faut
faire attention à ce que est-ce qu'elle
reste à taille
modéré moi j'ai Bigard dans ma
circonscription c'est évidemment le
siège le siège international de
l'entreprise Bigard mais il faut pas
tomber dans les caricatures sur sur
l'agriculture vous savez tout à l'heure
on va parler du beurre
pour faire du beurre il faut des vaches
et pour les vaches c'est un moyen
extraordinaire de créer de la bouille
biodiversité sur un territoire et donc
il faut pas dans les caricatures on a
des agriculteurs qui ont à qui on a
demandé de faire des choses à une époque
donnée aujourd'hui on leur demande autre
chose et il faut les accompagner plutôt
que les stigmatiser et moi j'y tiens
vraiment parce que parce que moi j'ai
des convictions écologiques et je crois
que les agriculteurs sur mon territoire
ils savent que j'ai des convictions et
écologiques et en réalité les partages
mais il faut les accompagner alors vous
savez qu'en France le
occupe une large place est
particulièrement en politique c'est pas
moi qui vais vous l'apprendre alors on
va passer à la brève de comptoir
on vous a demandé
Erwan Balanant de réfléchir un souvenir
politique autour d'un repas est-ce que
vous avez une idée qui vous est revenue
ouais j'ai plusieurs idées mais je me
suis je me suis souvenu d'un repas en
septembre au Conseil constitutionnel le
bureau de la commission des lois était
invité au Conseil constitutionnel alors
je me suis retrouvé étant vice-président
du Conseil constitutionnel du président
de la commission des lois pardon du
lapsus face à Sacha Houlier qui est le
président et puis donc j'avais à ma
droite et à ma gauche à ma droite
Laurent Fabius et à ma gauche Alain
Juppé et Alain Juppé et je trouve que
pour un cent triste à voir cette espèce
d'inversion droite-gauche et d'être au
centre c'était très bien et puis après
je les ai un petit peu bousculés dans le
repas mais avec beaucoup de respect
évidemment sur la décision qu'ils
avaient pris sur les sur les langues
régionales surtout il avait tout un
débat suite à la saisie du Conseil
constitutionnel et donc on a eu un débat
un peu passionné mais intéressant
j'avoue que d'avoir être député un
deuxième mandat et se retrouver près de
ce qu'on appelle les sages et quand on
est quand on est commissaire aux lois et
qu'on travaille beaucoup sur la
constitution c'est des moments qui sont
effectivement assez émouvants vous vous
souvenez ce que vous avez mangé je me
souviens que non je me souviens pas de
ce qu'on a mangé c'était très bon
j'étais très bon je me souviens que
c'était très bon mais je me souviens
plus de ce qu'on a mangé j'oublie assez
vite parce que j'aime tellement manger
que je fais tellement de restaurants que
voilà toujours en essayant d'avoir
trouvé des restaurants aussi qui soit
pas trop cher j'aime pas j'aime pas
aller dans les restaurants qui qui sont
très très chers voilà j'aime bien les
bons trouver les bons petits les bonnes
petites adresses pas nécessairement mais
voilà des des jeunes chefs qui vont
devenir bon et tout ça on va parler d'un
aliment que vous aimez beaucoup je crois
c'est le beurre parce que la France est
le premier consommateur de beurre
premier producteur d'Europe un aliment
fétiche que les Français consomment en
grande quantité
[Musique]
8 kg par an et par habitant c'est la
consommation moyenne des Français en
beurre alors difficile de s'en passer au
petit déjeuner pour cuisiner ou faire de
la pâtisserie il fait partie de leur
quotidien mais comme son prix fort et
bien de Londres à Paris certains vont
jusqu'à en fabriquer eux-mêmes à la
ferme de Gally Hélène Bonduelle et
Charlotte sebir l'ont constaté c'est
bien un jeu d'enfant
est-ce que certains ou certaines et si
ont déjà mangé du beurre
qui a déjà fabriqué du beurre personne
pourtant vous allez voir dans cet
atelier que fabriquer son beurre est un
jeu d'enfant encore faut-il savoir que
pour réaliser du beurre on va utiliser
du lait de vache oui
ça c'est bon un seul ingrédient suffit
de la crème entière bien fraîche
un pot hermétique bien sûr et surtout
beaucoup d'huile de coude il faut le
secouer fort fort fort fort fort fort
fort fort qui veut essayer
et quand tu en as marre tu donnes à ton
voisin
c'est le principe du baratin
ce qui se passe c'est que les boules de
gras à l'intérieur elles sont envoyées
dans tous les sens au bout d'un moment
elles vont se taper entre elles les
boules de gras le molécules de graves on
se coller et l'eau qui a des études en
tour de la molécule de graves tomber en
dessous et donc on va avoir une grosse
boule de gras au milieu avec toutes les
molécules qui ça qui se collent les unes
aux autres et l'eau qui d'habitude
entouré chaque petit bout de molécule
qui tombe en dessous écoutez bien
la boule c'est le beurre et l'eau font
du pot le babeur
ne reste plus qu'à filtrer puis rincez
le beurre le moulé
et déguster ça ressemble au vert
[Musique]
il est meilleur il est très bon
excellent bien crémeux
il est super bon et il est plus crémeux
donc moi je préfère et moi je sens la
différence par rapport au beurre du
supermarché ça m'a donné envie d'en
faire à la maison je pense que c'est
meilleur fait maison ça nous coûte moins
cher aussi ça donne envie de le refaire
on nous demande souvent quelle crème
utiliser quelle crème nous on a utilisé
est-ce que ça marche avec toutes les
crèmes ou est-ce que vous avez trouvé
votre crème alors ça marche avec
n'importe quelle crème entière sans
stabilisant et à la fin rien ne se perd
les enfants on va amener le babeur au
cochon
vous êtes fan de beurre je l'ai dit
juste avant est-ce que vous iriez
jusqu'à en fabriquer vous-même vous avez
déjà essayé mais ça donne envie
d'essayer ça a pas l'air
avant dans chaque ferme on faisait son
beurre mon père il me racontait des
histoires sur le beurre parce que le
beurre c'est fait avec du lait avant de
faire la crème il faut du lait et donc
la
vachement toute la saison la même chose
et dans mes parents sont originaires du
Nord Finistère ils faisaient des
artichauts et les vaches elles mangent
les artichauts ce qui donnaient un
beurre mais dégueulasse en réalité
très fin le beurre c'est à dire qu'on
peut le faire comme ça mais on peut
avoir des beurres de c'est très très
haute qualité et le beurre
quand c'est sans sel c'est pas du beurre
on est d'accord avec ça le beurre n'est
que de beurre quand il y a du sel
pourquoi on faisait du beurre dans les
fermes c'était pour conserver la crème
et le lait pour conserver les pour parce
qu'on boit pas que du voilà donc on les
coulait et pour et pour conserver la
meilleure il fallait et vraiment je le
dis tout le temps quand c'est même très
salé alors du coup
on peut le trouver aussi très salé en
Bretagne
généralement voilà il y a des cristaux
de sel alors ça dépend il y a des gens
qui mettent des cristaux de sel moi
j'aime moi je préfère pas trop moi
j'aime bien le beurre sans alors vous le
consommez quand vous le consomme tout le
temps parce que
vous savez à la buvette de l'Assemblée
quand je viens m'installer les les
agents les serveurs et ils viennent me
mettre du beurre et j'ai même pas le
demander un peu de pain
ils savent que voilà moi j'adore le pain
beurre le petit déjeuner c'est pain
beurre alors parfois un peu de miel un
peu de confiture mais pain beurre et
sinon après le beurre on le pense
comme ça à manger avec du pain mais
c'est aussi la base de la pâtisserie la
base des gâteaux et voilà donc vous
mettez du beurre sur votre pain avant de
manger de la confiture ou du fromage
alors confiture oui je mets au dessus
avant avant de prendre mon morceau de
fromage je effectivement je tartine
mon pain parce que comme ça c'est on est
sûr que voilà que c'est un camembert à
45% derrière
c'est un peu calorique aussi il faut le
dire c'est un peu calories de
cholestérol de Monsieur Erwan Balanant
je peux pas secret médical non je suis
sûr que ça va parce que je je pareil je
j'essaye d'être sur des produits de
qualité donc de pas trop en abuser mais
souvent je dis que le beurre le beurre
spot c'est bon pour la santé ça fait
glisser le cholestérol sur les parois
voilà alors modération aussi en France
il y a un match il y a le beurre d'un
côté puis alors les détenteurs du Sud
l'huile d'olive vous dans ce match les
Rolling Stones Beatles alors beurre
visiblement moi beurre naturellement
mais l'huile d'olive c'est excellent
aussi c'est délicieux j'en ai parlé tout
à l'heure
je cuisine au beurre mais je cuisine
aussi à l'huile d'olive les deux mais
l'huile d'olive c'est pareil c'est un
très bon produit et il faut faire
attention il faut pas acheter des huiles
d'olive qui sont pas toujours très très
bonnes de l'étranger souvent je sais pas
je sais pas si c'est meilleur pour la
santé je laisserai pas dire ce genre de
choses non le beurre c'est bon c'est pas
mauvais pour la santé le beurre non plus
j'ai beaucoup de débat avec certaines
personnes
donc en fait il y a quand même des
vertus au beurre mais c'est très très
calorique 760 calories pour 100 g non le
beurre répéter 760 calories pour 100 g
c'est un peu chargé quand même il faut
peut-être pas trop tôt
le beurre faire attention de pas le
brûler
maintenant dans les restaurants
d'ailleurs
quand il est brûlé alors bien bon beurre
blanc avec un poisson c'est délicieux on
y revient en Grande-Bretagne il y a une
femme qui fait son beurre elle-même qui
a eu des millions et des millions de
vues sur Tik Tok et elle réussit très
bien son beurre et pourquoi ils font le
beurre là-bas parce qu'en fait ça coûte
de plus en plus cher est-ce que vous
vous avez constaté la flambée sur les
étiquettes
ça coûte plus cher et puis surtout il y
a eu un moment où il y avait une pénurie
on a vu surtout parlé d'une pénurie il y
a eu une pénurie et il y a eu des
industriels qui en ont plat préparé de
qualité de tout à l'heure je parlais de
d'une entreprise bretonne qui fait de la
coquille Saint-Jacques elle avait des
elle avait dû elle a dû sécuriser son
approvisionnement
parce qu'elle achète aussi un beurre de
qualité et elle avait dû le sécuriser et
elle a pu le faire parce qu'elle était
très grosse consommation
je sais plus exactement ce qui s'était
passé mais comme par comme souvent nos
pénuries c'est par un petit coup de peur
et de sur achat vous savez la moutarde
la qui a disparu le rayons un moment
donné c'était pas parce qu'il y a plus
de moutarde c'est que tout le monde a
acheté de la bouteille il y avait plus
de graines de moutarde au Canada et en
Ukraine là le beurre on produit
énormément de lait je comprends pas
qu'en France on est une pénurie de
beurre alors qu'on produit du lait vous
l'avez dit lui-même avant le beurre il y
a du lait
parce que les vaches
et le surplus de lait qui est pour faire
du lait pour faire de la du beurre
visiblement plus compliqué que ça le
beurre les vaches du lait le lait le je
pense que lait tout aussi gras mais sauf
que les industriels et l'agro-industrie
l'agro-industrie valorise énormément le
beurre et le lait et le lait on appelle
il est craqué c'est à dire que quand le
quand vous achetez une barquette de lait
industriel et que vous la payez pas
assez cher parce que justement souvent
elle est pas payée elle est elle est pas
au bon prix l'industriel a valorisé tout
un tas de produits du lait que le lait
est un produit
qualitatif d'où le prix d'où le prix et
il faut il faut acheter des lait qui
sont des laits de proximité et de
regarder le prix quand vous achetez du
lait parce que 5 centimes de plus ou 10
centimes de plus sur votre alors je sais
que parfois pour des familles ça peut
être beaucoup mais ça permet ça permet
de payer le juste prix et payer le juste
prix pour les agriculteurs c'est leur
donner les moyens de vivre et c'est
aussi leur donner les moyens de faire la
transition écologique donc c'est
important de bien d'acheter les choses
alors juste prix on sait que le lait bio
aujourd'hui il a du mal à s'écouler le
ventre quasiment au du lait traditionnel
le marché du lait est un marché assez
compliqué il y a eu un moment donné où
il y avait pour les agriculteurs qui
étaient en bio c'était une vraie
plus-value après ça a été un peu plus
difficile mais aujourd'hui produire du
lait bio on sait aussi produire du lait
bio qui a la production ne coûte pas
beaucoup plus cher que du lait non bio
bah oui mais c'est tout un équilibre et
puis il faut pas opposer le bio et le
conventionnel c'est vrai que c'est mieux
le bio mais on le pose pas mais les
producteurs quand ils font du lait plus
cher et qu'il retrouve dans les mêmes
cuves que du lait normal
non mais le marché du lait est très
compliqué en plus on a des tensions sur
les rachats par vous savez quand vous
êtes producteur de lait le lait ça se
perd donc vous avez un temps Calais mais
il faut le vider tous les jours donc
c'est une sacrée logistique et c'est une
logistique qui coûte c'est aussi pour ça
que le lait coûte assez cher souvent le
match beurre artisanal beurre industriel
vous le venez
moi je j'essaye toujours d'avoir des il
y a des très bons producteurs de beurre
sur ma circonscription et le crémier
chez qui je vais à Quimperlé il a du
beurre il a du beurre à la coupe et donc
et c'est effectivement je vais on va pas
se mentir c'est un peu plus cher mais
mais c'est un produit c'est tellement de
qualité gustative autre et puis on en
prend un peu moins on essaye voilà et je
voulais dire tout à l'heure je la
conviction que faire ses courses en
proximité ça revient pas plus cher que
de faire les courses en supermarché et
ce beurre là il devient par an c'est un
petit peu très vite
faut pas qu'il soit trop froid il faut
pas qu'il soit resté au chaud et surtout
faut le couvrir parce qu'il prend le
beurre prend le goût des des produits du
alors on va parler à présent de la
sécheresse en Bretagne et
particulièrement dans le Finistère le
niveau des nappes phréatiques était très
bas jusqu'à fin octobre causant des
dégâts dans les cultures on en parle et
on met les pieds dans le plat
[Musique]
alors je voulais dire que c'est d'abord
la fin d'une idée reçue la Bretagne dont
on dit toujours qu'il pleut tout le
temps vit une sécheresse historique
depuis cet été nappe phréatico plus bas
et un drame pour les agriculteurs une
production d'artichauts qui a chuté de
près de 50% si on prend l'ensemble du
territoire breton nous avons un
reportage dans le Finistère de Diane
karcher
chez cet agriculteur finistérien l'été a
laissé des séquelles température élevée
et manque d'eau un cocktail mortel pour
ses artichauts habitués au climat breton
plutôt que d'avoir une plante qui est
qui nous arrive à la taille voire voir
plus haut ben vous voyez ce que ça a
donné le stress hydrique qu'on a eu des
artichauts deux fois plus petit que
d'habitude pour ceux qui ont résisté au
total Jean-Yves Masson a perdu 60% de sa
production comme de nombreuses
exploitants de la région il veut
aujourd'hui remplacer l’artichaut par
des cultures moins exigeantes en eau
comme le brocoli ou le chou romanesco il
va falloir se poser les bonnes questions
très rapidement parce que des pertes de
l'ordre de 70 80.000 euros comme on a
subi cette année
il est clair que on ne pourra pas
continuer comme ça il va falloir prendre
une décision fin 2023 l'agriculteur a
pourtant pu compter cet été sur son
système d'irrigation dans cette réserve
il stocke l'eau de pluie qui ruisselle
mais avec si peu de précipitations
ça n'a pas suffi le niveau plein est
au-dessus du tuyau
et là donc vous voyez un peu ce qui est
ce qui manque quoi
il y a un peu d'eau encore à venir et là
il y a rien qui coule donc c'est pas bon
signe parce que l'année dernière ça
coulait bien c'était possible cette
hydrologue le confirme la situation est
préoccupante dans le Finistère les
restrictions de mise en place en août
viennent seulement d'être levées mais le
niveau des cours d'eau reste bas si vous
voulez à cette date-ci un débit comme ça
on le voit une année sur 10 une
situation qui va engendrer des conflits
entre le monde agricole et les citoyens
la demande croit demande des populations
le consommateur d'eau breton consomme
plus d'eau que il y a 10 ans
il consomme plus de % par an il y a
beaucoup plus d'activités économiques il
y a toujours autant d'animaux et puis on
a une demande agricole qui est en
croissance et qui pose un problème parce
que la ressource reste extrêmement
limitée
pour se spécialiste pas question
d'irriguer plus il faut produire
autrement Jean-Yves Masson fait le même
constat sur son exploitation il a décidé
de planter des arbres pour faire de
l'ombre et donc conserver l'humidité des
sols on a un tilleul ça permettra de
refroidir la culture beaucoup plus vite
quoi c'est le principe de la série autre
piste améliorer la qualité des sols pour
leur permettre de mieux retenir cette
eau qui devient rare notamment en
alternant les cultures d'une année sur
l'autre
alors Erwan vous avez dans votre famille
des producteurs d'artichaut vous les
avez vu ces plans là aujourd'hui qui
arrivent jusqu'au genou alors que
d'habitude jusqu'à l'épaule ça va être
assez ça le triste à voir c'est
compliqué surtout dans le nord Finistère
tout à l'heure vous parliez de nappe
phréatique en réalité en Bretagne et
dans le mystère il y a pas de nappes
phréatique on a des autres surfaces et
donc quand il pleut plus du tout c'est
compliqué donc il faut avoir une
réflexion
géologique des sols il y a pas on n'a
pas de nappe phréatique mais on a de
l'eau parce qu'il pleut effectivement il
pleut pas tant que ça d'ailleurs il
pleut il pleut modérément
tous les jours non plus
cet été il a fait très beau par exemple
la preuve ça pose des soucis de
sécheresse non mais sur l'eau il faut il
faut qu'on ait une vraie réflexion il
faut que tout ça se coordonne au niveau
au niveau du département et au niveau
régional aussi parce que on a parlé du
Finistère et du Nord Finistère et des
cultivateurs d'artichauts on a d'autres
problématiques fortes sur le bassin
rennais et tout ça il faut
interconnecter mais sur l'eau vous savez
avec les histoires des bassines il y a
eu beaucoup de polémiques
il pleut
500 milliards de mètres cubes sur la
France après l'évaporation et après
l'eau qu'on reçoit de nos frontières
parce qu'il y a aussi de l'eau qui
arrive par la terre de nos frontières on
est à peu près à 300
milliards de mètres cubes l'irrigation
c'est 3 milliards de mètres cubes
évidemment qui qui va qu'on va utiliser
nous ça c'est une consommation qui est
importante l'industrie consomme de l'eau
aussi mais on a des
usines de retraitement voilà mais on a
aussi agriculteur laissé faites des
bassines
il y a des endroits il y a des
territoires dans certains endroits où il
faut effectivement avoir des retenues
d'eau mais l'humanité a passé son temps
à retenir l'eau et donc il faut pas être
il faut pas avoir une vision
complètement dogmatique l'humanité a
passé son temps à faire des biefs à
retenir l'eau à la ralentir donc il faut
en plus maintenant
il y a un réchauffement climatique c'est
pas moi qui vais le nier vous connaissez
mes convictions écologiques mais de ce
qu'on sait c'est que on aura autant
d'eau à tomber sur nos territoires
national mais avec des différent de ce
qui sont aujourd'hui avec des moments de
sécheresse et donc des précipitations
les moments de sécheresse donc il faut
s'organiser pour avoir une gestion de ce
volume d'eau pour qu'il puisse répondre
aux usages les usages particuliers les
usages d'alimentation et quand je dis
alimentation c'est effectivement
l'irrigation parce que si on veut des
légumes des fruits il n'y a pas de
secret ça se fait pas sans eau et il y a
une autre chose qui se fait pas sans eau
aussi c'est la biodiversité à partir du
moment où vous avez plus d'eau vous avez
plus de vidéos diversité donc il faut il
faut s'organiser et il faut avoir c'est
une bonne organisation il faut avoir des
gestions intelligentes et non
dogmatiques tout simplement ça dépend
des territoires et une bassine si elle
est bien
configurée si effectivement elle est pas
l'évaporation aussi alors il y a
l'évaporation mais mais justement moi en
Bretagne si on n'a pas de naturétique
mais si on a de l'eau toute l'année
parce qu'il peut pas toute l'année en
Bretagne évidemment l'été il fait beau
c'est parce qu'on a un un certain nombre
de zones humides on a un certain nombre
de cours d'eau c'est-à-dire vous avez
les rivières et puis le chevelu des
rivières c'est tous les petits ruisseaux
tout ça ça maintient l'eau et donc c'est
ça qu'il faut garder c'est et en
Bretagne on a aussi un bocage les
bocages les talus ça garde l'eau vous
savez les agriculteurs ils le savent
très bien quand ils font quand ils font
certaines cultures ils savent très bien
que la production suivant le type de
culture c'est ça qui est un peu un peu
particulier et meilleur à proximité du
talus mais il y a d'autres cultures qui
marchent bien donc il faut avoir cette
intelligence l'humain n'a pas arrêté de
sculpter la nature alors on peut avoir
une vision un peu romantique de la
disparition de l'humain mais je suis pas
sûr que la biodiversité va complètement
gagner aussi donc on a une interaction
homme
nature on a longtemps été un peu maître
et dominateur de ce de ce monde il faut
qu'on devienne tuteur et protecteur de
notre planète on l'a vu dans ce
reportage
l'agriculteur plante arbres aussi pour
faire de l'ombre aussi pour rester pour
les les racines qui vont aller chercher
l'eau ça c'est on peut planter des haies
il y a comme ça des Bretagne on l'a fait
depuis des siècles et des siècles c'est
à dire qu'on a un paysage de bocage qui
qui qui
se structure la vallée les vallées et
qui maintiennent l'eau et donc on a eu
une période un peu funeste ou on pensait
avoir des grands champs et que ça allait
être efficace et donc on a coupé des
maintenant il y a des plans pour refaire
des haies il faut continuer mais tout à
l'heure je parlais de l'élevage vous
savez l'élevage les vaches elles ont
besoin de champs modérés elles ont pas
besoin de champ énorme à partir du
moment on a plus d'élevage qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire si on a plus d'élevage on
va faire du blé par exemple dans notre
territoire pour faire du blé
naturellement on va faire des très
grands champs et donc si on fait des
très grands champs on va avoir des
impacts néfastes sur sur les écoulements
d'eau sur l'évaporation etc donc il faut
faire confiance à recherche l'agronomie
est une science précise et qui une
science qui peut apporter beaucoup de
choses et la transition écologique se
fera aussi avec les agriculteurs qui
vont changer un certain nombre de
pratiques ce qu'il faut sans paysans
beaucoup d'eau
on arrête peut-être de faire de
l'artichaut ou on change de culture
du chou romanes
peut-être que peut-être qu'il va y avoir
des transitions peut-être qu'il va y
avoir des adaptations et puis sur ces
régions là sur la région du Léon on va
peut-être pouvoir aussi avoir quelques
retenues d'eau qu'on va faire pour
pouvoir irriguer un peu enfin il faut
pas tomber il faut pas être dans les
caricatures si on veut parler de la
transition c'est comme ça qu'on est la
meilleure façon de tout rater moi vous
savez la France elle a des paysages
merveilleux et ces paysages ils sont
issus du monde paysan et du travail de
la terre et donc si on veut garder
paysage si on veut garder tout ce que ça
comme effet positif sur l'écologie sur
sur la vie il faut qu'on continue à
avoir des paysans tout simplement j'ai
une question de gourmand parce que moi
j'aime bien manger alors ces artichauts
breton si on a beaucoup parlé de la
sécheresse des sols mais alors ils sont
trop petits donc ils sont avantables à
mangeable et ouais et puis surtout le
problème c'est qu'il y a eu un moment
donné vous savez la grande distribution
qui en achète beaucoup pour les écouler
alors vous voulez pas parce qu'ils
étaient trop petits et ça il faut
changer il faut qu'on ait des règles
pour que pour que il y ait une
solidarité aussi de la grande
distribution quand vous avez des légumes
différents
j'ai pas mangé d'artichaut encore cette
année et c'est pas pareil que
l'artichaut poivrade pour les c'est pas
du tout l'artichaut breton c'est le très
gros et l'artichaut on peut avoir des
petits mais naturellement petit naturel
vous en faites aussi en Bretagne du
poivre chez nous l'artichaut
traditionnel c'est l'artichaut de de
Saint-Paul le Léon voilà
une Vina on prend l'assiette on met sa
cuillère comme ça pour que l'assiette
la sauce coule au fond et on et à la
cuillère comme ça ouais
cocotte-minute alors ma mère elle me
disent toujours de le elle me dit
toujours d'ailleurs de le laver de le
laver de le cuire en deux fois c'est à
dire première cuisson on change l'eau on
remet une deuxième cuisson
moi j'aime bien je sais pas si vous en
avez déjà mangé je pense que c'est avec
ces gros artichauts bretons c'est en
Italie c'est des artichauts à la romaine
quand ils les font frire ça c'est bon
alors moi j'ai une passion pour la
l'art culinaire italien les Italiens
sont très très forts aussi avec un petit
peu d'huile d'olive
et comme disait Coluche il y en a plus à
la fin du repas
on va passer au dessert à présent et
c'est notre péché mignon
oui voici venu le temps du sucré
Brigitte avec un gâteau breton que vous
nous avez même apporté sans dit long sur
la confiance que vous nous accordez pour
réaliser ce must de la pâtisserie
bretonne dont la trace remontrait les
magnifiques à 1863 alors sur internet je
suis allé regarder gâteau breton alors
foisonne les recettes du vrai gâteau
breton dont les ingrédients se résume à
de la farine des œufs du sucre et du
beurre on pourrait penser donc tous les
gâteaux pour apparaître que tous les
gâteaux bretons se ressemblent mais je
sens que vous le Breton vous n'êtes pas
tout à fait cet avis non il y a autant
de gâteaux bretons quasiment de famille
il y a des familles qui rajoutent un
petit verre de rhum dedans pour donner
un petit peu de goût il y a des gens qui
le découpent avec la confine au milieu
qui met de la confiture ou du de la
confiture de pruneaux alors les pruneaux
c'est souvent dans le phare mais moi je
suis un ayatollah du phare nature sans
pruneau voilà et alors le gâteau breton
c'est beaucoup de beurre effectivement
donnez-nous les proportions de celui-ci
j'ai presque une proportion comme un
quatre-quart quoi il y a eu tant de
beurre que de il y a plus de beurre que
de farine je pense que ça allait au-delà
j'ai pas les je pense que s'il est très
heureux c'est au-delà du 4K
plusieurs recettes ça va de 250 g à 350
g de 300 farine bah j'ai pas regardé ça
je me suis focalisé sur le beurre mais
je me suis dit que 350 g de beurre moi
je sais que c'est 300 € par an dans ma
dans ma recette c'est 300 g de beurre et
je crois que c'est 200 g de farine de
souvenirs donc c'est donc c'est pas un
4/4 c'est plus de barbe plus de bruit et
Puiseux c'est pareil les œufs il faut
des bons œufs alors moi j'ai appris
parce que je suis pas Breton comme
Brigitte que la découpe du gâteau breton
c'était tout un art donc vous avez
souffert
grosse pression et ça se découpe surtout
pas comme une tarte ça se découpe pour
faire des losanges
ça se découpe on fait comme ça pour moi
c'est une résine alors
vous avez des marques là vous suivez les
marques
des Bretons pour faire ça je vais avoir
découper comme ça vous suivez les
marques à proximité
parce que c'est Annie qui a une crêpière
à Quimperlé qui a une petite boutique
qui a longtemps eu une petite boutique
dans les halles et puis maintenant qu'il
y a sa boutique et qui qui fait ce
gâteau
bretoné mais c'est pas grave je me fais
engueuler mais donc là ça veut dire que
vous voyez quelque part avec beaucoup de
croûte d'autres avec quelqu'un pour tous
les goûts c'est exactement il y a des
gens qui aiment il y a des gens qui
aiment le
croquant et il y a par exemple souvent
vous savez c'est souvent un gâteau qu'on
fait dans les kermesse dans les fêtes
populaires et tout ça et donc il y a des
gens qui le font dans des plats carrés
ah oui ça règle ça règle si cette
question et alors c'est un gâteau qui se
conserve très longtemps voilà et il
était souvent emmené en mer parce que
les marins qui restaient assez longtemps
en mer trouver du coup en manger pendant
plusieurs semaines voilà là j'ai un peu
bon c'est pas parfait
ça devrait pas exister ce petit bout là
normalement voilà mais c'est le stress
de de
couper le gâteau et après
mais c'est moi c'est délicieux vous avez
déjà essayé
qui était chez moi et qui et j'ai trouvé
le sien particulièrement bon je lui ai
demandé la recette mais j'ai pas encore
j'ai pas encore testé j'ai pas encore
fait mais c'est simple c'est pas c'est
un coup de main oui et puis peut-être
pour la cuisson pour que il soit pas toi
quelle température 180 la température
classique
je pensais pas qu'il serait si ferme
donc
merci avouer Juan Malan merci à vous
tous de nous avoir suivis et on se
retrouve bien sûr la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LC